In this problem, a given 18in reinforced
concrete sewer with a manning end of
0.013 is being installed to transport
storm water away from a detention basin.
For every 100 ft of length, the vertical
change will be 0.5 ft. If the sewer is
required to achieve a minimum velocity
of 2 feet per second to prevent
sedimentation, what should the depth in
this sewer be? So this problem provides
us with an opportunity to solve
something called partial flows. We can
do this in about four steps
below. First, we have enough information
to use Manning's equation to calculate
the velocity in the sewer when the sewer
is flowing full. Manning's equation can
be found in section
6.4.5.1 if you need to see it.
This is going to be equal to V equ=
1.486 over the Manning
N*
the hydraulic radius to the
2/3 time slope to the
1/2. Hydraulic radius as you may recall
is the area over the wetted perimeter.
We can solve for area and wetted
perimeter and then plug this back into
the hydraulic
radius. So the equation for area is
going to
be pi * d diameter squar /
4. In our problem, that's going to be pi
* 1.5 feet from the 18 inches here
squared over
4. And our area is going to solve out to
1.77 square
ft. The weded perimeter is going to be
equal to 2 *<unk> * the radius,
otherwise known as the diameter over
two.
So in this it's going to be 2 *<unk>
* 1.5
ft /
2. And this is going to solve out to
about
4.71 ft.
Putting 1.77 over
4.71 solves out to about
0.375T which is our hydraulic
radius. The slope value we can see from
the problem says for every 100 ft of
length the vertical change will be 0.5
ft. So following our convention of rise
over run we will do 0 5 vertical feet
over 100 ft and this will give us
0.00 five and this will be our slope
value. So plugging all of these terms
into Manning's equation we can see
that
1.486 over 0.013
013 from up
here
times
0.375
ft to the
2/3 times
0.5 square
root. And this will calculate out to
just about
4.2 ft per second when the pipe is
flowing
full. So step
two is going to
be finding the ratio of the minimum
desired velocity to the full pipe
velocity.
And this is really
easy. We're just going to plug in our
minimum velocity of 2 feet per second
over
4.2t per second and get a ratio of 0.48.
Now step
three
involves going to the plot in section
6.4.5.3 to find the hydraulic element
plot or the partial flow plot. I will
include a screenshot
here tracing up on the xaxis from 0.48
48 which we calculated in step
two. We can stop at the solid line for
velocity. This is because in partially
filled sewer pipes the n value can often
vary with the flow
depth. Next we can trace to the left
x-axis and we can find our ratio of flow
depth to diameter.
And this value is just about 0.2.
Now all we have to do for step four is
to apply this ratio to our current pipe
size. So we have 0.2
* 1.5
ft and converting back
to 12
in per foot.
Forgot to note here that depth is in
inches. And this will solve out to about
3.6
in which is our first answer over
here. Some quick notes. Um due to the
nature of partially filled pipes, we
can't apply our ratio calculated for the
velocity directly to the depth.
Nor can we plug in the velocity of two
and back calculate for depth since we
wouldn't know the geometry of the
partially full
pipe. This is why we are using the
partial flow diagram to solve this
problem.
So, if you're comfortable with Manning's
equation and you remember that this plot
exists on the exam, you'll be in great
shape if you come across a question
where you are asked to find a given
velocity or flow at a given depth within
a sewer. And that's it.